ist tot vielleicht doch gar nicht
unbedingt tod diese frage spiegelt eine
echte uhr angst vieler menschen wieder
aktuelle untersuchungen mit schweine
hirn lassen das vermuten fachleuten aus
den usa ist es nämlich gelungen in den
organen stunden nach dem tod der tiere
zelluläre funktionen wiederherzustellen
klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen in vielen medien wird dieses
forschungsergebnis aus den usa als
medizinisches wunder gefeiert das
renommierte fachmagazin nature wird mit
dem thema sogar seine titelseite die
zeit zurückdrehen heißt es hier
die heiß diskutierten
forschungsergebnisse erinnern stark an
frankenstein und kommen von dem
hirnforscher senat gestern von der yale
school of medicine sein team hatte für
das experiment schweine köpfe aus
schlachthöfen genutzt und das hirn der
tiere heraus operiert in einer extra
dafür entwickelten paar fusions maschine
namens brain ex wurden diese sechs
stunden lang mit einer komplexen
mischung aus nährstoffen und künstlichem
blut durch strömt das ergebnis ist
erstaunlich denn die fachleute wollen
lebenszeichen beobachtet haben und das
obwohl diese behandlung ganze vier
stunden nach dem tod der tiere gestartet
wurde dazu der forscher nehmen als es
dann das gehirn scheint ein bisher
unterschätztes potenzial zur
wiederherstellung bestimmter molekularer
und zellulärer aktivitäten zu besitzen
konkret verlangsamte sich der zelltod
der nervenzellen und in einigen fällen
konnten demnach sogar zeichen von
funktionsfähigkeit nachgewiesen werden
sauerstoff haushalt und energie balance
in den isolierten gehirn normalisierten
sich und noch mehr bei der
elektrophysiologischen stimulation in
hirnschnitten ließen sich den angaben
des forschungsteams zufolge sogar
synaptische aktivitäten nachweisen
dieses ergebnis erinnert eine eine
aufsehenerregende studie von vor 50
jahren in der gehirne von katzen und
affen eine stunde nach einem
kreislaufstillstand wiederbelebt werden
konnten
nach angaben der beteiligten fachleute
zeige das aktuelle experiment dass dies
auch noch nach mehreren stunden möglich
sein
doch an dieser stelle muss eines
deutlich gesagt werden eine messbare
funktion des gehirns
als ganzes ist keinesfalls nachgewiesen
worden
dazu heißt es in der studie zu keinem
zeitpunkt haben wir organisierte
umfassende elektrische aktivität
beobachtet die auf bewusstsein
wahrnehmung oder andere höhere
hirnfunktionen hinweisen würden
detaillierte untersuchungen dazu waren
im vorfeld von der ethikkomission
untersagt worden und so hatten die us
fachleute die nervenaktivität extra
durch bestimmte blogger unterdrückt das
forschungsteam selbst feiert die
ergebnisse dennoch auch wenn diese
derzeit noch nicht für konkrete
klinische anwendung genutzt werden
können doch in zukunft könnte diese
methode eine bessere möglichkeit bieten
tote säugetier organe zu untersuchen
langfristig gesehen hoffen die
beteiligten experten und expertinnen
dass ähnliche verfahren zukünftig auch
bei patienten und patientinnen mit
hirnschäden wie beispielsweise einem
schlaganfall zum einsatz kommen könnten
durch die präsentation dieses
experiments in vielen medien kommen
ethische fragen auf bedeutet tod gar
nicht unbedingt tod wann ist ein gehirn
wirklich tot müssen wir unser
verständnis des hirntodes überdenken
fest steht in fachkreisen wird die
studie stark kritisiert und zwar nicht
wegen der methodik sondern weil sie
unbegründet die diskussionen aufwerfe
das sagt zum beispiel der vorsitzende
des deutschen ethikrates peter dabrock
die präsentation der studie im
fachmagazin nature sei nicht angebracht
und unnötig sensation zeichen
schließlich ging es thematisch um das
aufflackern von lebensspuren auf
zellulären ebenen keinesfalls sei es nun
angebracht die definition des todes in
frage zu stellen oder gar zu
überarbeiten dazu peter dabrock das
hirntod kriterium grundsätzlich in frage
zu stellen scheint mir nach
gegenwärtigem kenntnisstand nicht
richtig zu sein denn es zieht sie ja nie
auf die zelluläre sondern die funktional
systemische ebene und auch andere
fachleute die nicht an der studie
beteiligt waren betonen die strengen
regelungen in deutschland bezüglich der
intro diagnose vor allem bezüglich der
organtransplantation ist das natürlich
eine sehr emotionale thematik und die
definition des todes über das gilt es
hier entscheidend fest steht eine
entnahme von organen in deutschland darf
grundsätzlich erst nach dem hirntod
stattfinden nervenzellen im gehirn
sterben schon nach wenigen minuten
ohne sauerstoffversorgung ab und
entscheidende hirnfunktionen fallen
reparabel aus zwei mediziner müssen vor
einer organentnahme übereinstimmend und
nach mindestens zwölf stunden erneut
ausfall symptome des gehirns
diagnostizieren können wir unser gehirn
hecken super video von doktor watson
anklicken und natürlich bis zum ende
schauen und dr watson abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran